hey what's up mkbhd here
you either die a hero or live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
it's such a good quote mostly because
it's true
and in this case we just saw lg die a
hero
that's all so it's officially official
lg is shutting down their smartphone
business they will not be making any
more smartphones
um and when this news dropped a couple
nights ago i bet most people were in
one of two camps one oh
bummer that's too bad or two oh
lg was still making smartphones which is
wild because not only did lg make
smartphones but lg has made a lot of
really influential phones that have had
a direct impact on
the phone you're probably holding right
now so this is big news lg is a big
company
them leaving smartphones is pretty big
news but
how did this happen well we already know
lg's been making phones for a long time
and it's tempting to think if at least
you're around my age
that their heyday was probably in like
the mid 2000s
with phones like the lg voyager lg envy
lg chocolate those were i know a lot of
people that had those phones those are
very popular phones my first
ever smartphone was the lg voyager i'm
considering this a smartphone and i
started this
channel when i had that phone and i even
did a few videos
about it but yeah lots of other people
had various lg
semi smartphones from around that time
and i mean
a lot of people 21 million people bought
the lg chocolate but it might surprise
you to know that
their most popular android phone of all
time
was the g3 that came out in 2014 so that
was their peak for smartphone stuff
that phone sold 10 million units and
their second most popular android phone
of all time was the g2 and that sold
around 3 million so clearly there was a
decline
lg never found those sales again they
never had any single smartphone come out
after that
that competed on a massive scale in any
price bracket they didn't have a hit
budget phone they didn't really have
anything that started doing numbers in
the mid-range
and they never really achieved much
presence in the high-end market either
as far as market share
and all this was despite having a lot of
the same specs
and materials and features on paper
as the ones that did find success but
phone purge decisions
are not made on paper and so my take is
lg actually did make decent phones on
paper
but they did not know how to sell
those phones like at all like what's the
most basic art in the world of marketing
naming stuff right just simple memorable
understandable name and i'm definitely
not saying all the other manufacturers
have got naming down because they
haven't but just having something
simple easy to understand is important
you know i know that iphone 12 pro
does more than iphone 12 i know that the
12 is newer
than the 11. i'm not saying naming your
phone
lg v60 thin
q 5g
made it a worse phone i'm just saying it
didn't help
i don't know why lg was so insistent on
those extra words like thin
q that doesn't mean anything to
anyone here but they kept adding it
anyway but okay
just forgetting naming forget even what
you might think of the software
uh lg's phones never really got great
marketing treatment they had pretty
forgettable
marketing to be perfectly honest and as
many have pointed out
found it kind of difficult to
characterize lg phones
which isn't necessarily a bad thing it's
just forgettable it honestly kind of
feels like a
like a washer and a dryer it's like
their marketing of their smartphones was
right along the same lines as the
marketing of their other appliances
shining but the crazy thing is
the actual character of lg phones
over these years is really interesting
and super low-key influential
so over the past eight years or so i'd
say
lg has been one of the few companies
that actually tries
very new things like super wild things
kind of anything really
but that's been their sort of motto is
just throwing a bunch of stuff at the
wall
and seeing what'll stick and sometimes
it really did stick
look at this list in march 2007 we had
lg prada that was the first
capacitive touch screen smartphone
pretty much every smartphone today has a
capacitive touch screen
in 2010 lg optimus 2x came out that was
the first
dual core processor smartphone ever and
the first to do 1080p video recording
then the next year lg optimus 3d was the
first phone
with more than one rear camera think
about that when's the last time you saw
a flagship with only one rear camera
they also
had the first quad core phone the lg
optimus 4x
then it gets serious in september 2013
lg g2
is the first phone to have double tap to
wake at the time they just called it the
knock knock feature
that the first mass-produced qhd display
in a phone
that was the lg g3 then the v10 would
technically be the first
dual screen phone thanks to the second
screen embedded up top
maybe that's a stretch but there are
some dual screen phones out now but then
the lg
g5 was the first phone with an ultra
wide camera
on the back then the g6 was the first
with an 18 by 9 display having a little
bit of that taller aspect ratio to keep
it narrower and fit better in the hand
and then v40 was the first phone with
all three focal lengths on the back
cameras
one ultra wide one standard and one
telephoto so it would be pretty easy to
miss if you weren't paying attention but
it turns out
lg has been important as far as
introducing
new ideas that hooked and sort of
got taken for granted today i don't know
if you can even buy that many
smartphones
at the high end that don't have an ultra
wide
and tap to wake and a high resolution
display these are all
really good things that caught on that
we see everywhere because they turned
out to be good ideas
but there were also plenty of things
that didn't catch on like that mini
display on the top of the v10 and v20
we don't really see that anymore this
self-healing back on the back of the g
flex really cool idea you don't really
see that anymore either
they tried curved phones for a while too
because they were supposed to be more
natural to holding your hand and up
against your face
that didn't last long they also had that
one modular phone that one year with the
g5
it was super cool but a year later they
were done making modules for it and
the whole ecosystem folded and then the
g8 is the most memorable
recent one for me so that had an ir
sensor array
for reading the veins in your hand and
these weird gestures that barely worked
when these things
didn't catch on the next year they were
gone
they just dropped it it was just gone
from the next phone and
that makes sense but it's also kind of
unnerving as a customer like what we
look for
in a long-term commitment to a phone is
stability and reliability
and consistency and at least being
somewhat predictable that
these things will be useful for a long
time and so it's not likely you'll want
to buy into an ecosystem
of modules if you don't even know it'll
be around the next year you know and
that's not even considering
lg's pretty bad track record of actually
delivering
software updates to their phones which
just adds into the whole
not very predictable stability thing now
there's a lot of talk
i've noticed about how maybe
youtubers are responsible for lg's
downfall
because we didn't give them enough
credit
let's talk about that so i went back to
check just because i was curious turns
out i've done about
20 videos about lg smartphones over the
past few years
20 videos and that's not including all
of the nexuses
i loved that lg also made one of the
earliest videos i ever had go
somewhat viral on this channel was my
video on the self-healing
of the lg g-flex from back in 2013. and
believe it or not the most
viewed single piece of content i have
ever made
happens to be me showing the lg wing to
32
million people on tick tock so the
problem isn't a lack of coverage
people talk about lg phones the real
question a lot of people are asking is
was this coverage fair
because if you if you watched these
videos you might still be wondering if
lg got the credit they deserve so my
take is
there's a big difference between
sharing a product with the world and
giving it credit for
something new or some innovation or an
idea we haven't seen before
versus reviewing and
actually recommending a product overall
to buy for a purchase decision
two very different things and so what
i've started to notice with that is i
can speak for myself
basically there's a big distinction
between innovation and trying something
new
and being able to recommend something to
a large variety of people
and phones that do well in one bucket
often
don't do well in the other it goes both
ways
c sony for example i'll leave that video
linked below and so i think over the
years
there's actually been a lot of giving lg
credit for all of that
trying new things and being unique
especially with hardware because they
clearly did a lot of that
throwing stuff at the wall to see what
would stick every time they showed
something interesting and new
i was there to give it a shot and point
a camera at it and share my findings
with you all
this self-healing g-flex was such a fun
experiment the modular g5 design was
a favorite it was impressively well
thought out and the multiple cameras on
the back of the v40 were fun
right from the beginning even if the
software features they built into that
version to take advantage of them was
a little wonky so yes absolutely
checking the boxes
in the innovation bucket and trying new
things for sure
but then when it came to reviews and
actually deciding okay now do we
recommend this
thing to a large group of people lg
phones
as an overall package were always a
little bit tough to recommend
to those larger groups even recently
uh v60 pretty great overall phone
but a 60 hertz display in a flagship
when all the competition had moved on to
higher fresh rate
was tough or even lg wing was
cool as hell but 765g
in a thousand dollar phone was kind of
tough to recommend
and it just continues as you go back lg
g8
might be the most perfect example
of an lg smartphone from the past few
years possible like this was a really
solid phone
right high-end chip pretty solid design
very modest of course no camera bump
kept
the headphone jack with the quad dac
kept expandable storage
decent battery and the killer feature
vane id yeah that was the new thing they
decided to throw out the wall
so the extra big notch in a phone of
this year
had a time-of-flight sensor an infrared
sensor and receiver
to identify your hand and let you do
gestures over the phone with your hand
and it really didn't work that well at
all you should have seen the room
full of journalists and youtubers
and pr reps all with this brand new
phone as we're trying to make our videos
about it
everyone's trying to do the thing to get
it to work
and no one can even we're a room full of
professionals even trained professionals
from lg are like if you just get it just
it was brutal so if you're gonna share
that phone you're gonna do one of two
things
one is give it credit for actually
trying something new and
maybe it's a it's a weird unusual set of
sensors we've never seen before but
highlighting the cool thing
or reviewing it and like packaging it
all overall to see if it's actually
worth buying
versus a competition for most people and
look i called it in my review the jack
of all trades
and master of none which i thought was
true but also apparently was pretty
harsh apparently people thought i was
being a little too hard on the phone i
didn't really think so
i was also far from the most negative
take on the g8 but here's the thing the
point
is when you take a step back the most
innovative
unique unproven stuff that you do in
your gadget
is almost by definition useful to the
smallest number of people
and this is true for every phone
manufacturer now normally this isn't a
huge problem
because if the smartphone company is
making money
somewhere then yeah they can designate
one of their lines to be
the unique innovative taking one like
samsung is a perfect example of this
they have their money making flagships
so those don't take big risks so they
crank out
all kinds of risky unproven foldy ideas
in other product lines just to kind of
see what sticks
xiaomi has their money making phones so
the mix series
is specifically consistently the one
where they try out their wild designs
vivo if you've noticed is basically oppo
group's innovation brand so with lg
and this is my own analysis i don't i
haven't seen their books but
they didn't really have a steady
consistent
money maker they didn't have some other
smartphone that was winning them
lots of market share so they could
afford to subsidize a risk-taking one
their main line was the fun one it was
the risk-taking one
and so this was just a straight business
decision so you can read the official lg
press release explaining why they left
the smartphone market
and it has this statement which is lg's
strategic decision to exit the
incredibly competitive mobile phone
sector
will enable the company to focus
resources in growth areas like
electric vehicle components connected
devices smart homes
robotics ai and business to business
solutions as well as platforms and
services
so basic translation lg does a bunch of
other stuff as a company
monitors tvs appliances we already know
and so
cutting off the smartphone division that
was losing money is just a decision that
allows them to focus on other things
that might grow up more
so what happens now well uh if you were
thinking about buying an lg phone
don't uh if you already have an lg phone
uh you can check the list there's
they've promised a small list of phones
we'll continue to get
i guess one more update up to the
android 12 update
we'll see hopefully they can support
phones as long as they can before they
disappear
but there's definitely there's a lot of
talent and a lot of patents over there
what they decide to do with that
infrastructure
is anybody's guess but i think the moral
of the story of lg
is innovation and trying new things
and risk taking is great but
it requires a balance of also some
stability
and long-term consistency and lg just
wasn't
quite able to strike that balance but
the real bummer is losing lg
is an l for all of us just because that
is
it's a competitor that's that's one less
set of cool ideas
that's going to be tried out like who
knows how many other
ultra wide or multiple camera type ideas
that they would have had that we won't
get to see now
and that's one less competitor to
incentivize the other bigger companies
to really
keep their stuff together and and win
over our business so
we've lost other smartphone companies
before but lg
feels like the biggest one as of late
feels like the biggest
space the biggest void being left in the
market anyway the point of this video
isn't for me to like defend myself like
i killed lg
but you know the the question of what
happened to lg
isn't just explained away by saying oh
the big youtubers didn't give lg enough
credit
the truth is always more nuanced than
that even if you believe that to be true
and this truth is this was a business
decision that
lg was probably thinking about for a
long time so you either
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself
become the villain and lg just died a
hero
rip lg smartphones you'll be missed not
because we were all using your phones
but because
you did move the needle uh that's been
pretty much it
shout out to mr mobile who's also
dropping a sort of a retrospective video
looking back at some of lg's finer
moments
i saw he was working on it i haven't
seen the video yet but i'm gonna link it
below when he does drop it because i
imagine it'll be pretty good
either way that's been it thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
[Music]
peace